oh but I want to ask about your tattoos
so you are getting uh you're getting
Inked out what is it is there a term for
it's really fascinating looking reminds
me one of those hairless cats kind of
yeah I have hairless cats um yeah I just
I've been blacking out all my tattoos
and so I'm in the process I have like
almost 80% of my body done now oh my God
yeah but I'm not it's not going to look
like a like I'm wearing a scuba diving
like bang it's G to I'm going to have
like these like black flowers kind of
you know so how black how long does this
process take kind of do all that I think
I'm I'm up to 40 40 hours now so but but
I mean I've done like the arms yeah but
in increments I you know I go and I
can't sit for more than two or three
hours and there's this guy in in Philly
that um he like specializes in it but
it's funny because you know when I first
got into tattooing was during a time
when there was no tattoo shows or
anything so it was like you would not
get hired if you had a face tattoo or
you know what I mean it was a different
era and then I think when like certain
celebrities started getting tattooed
like the drewberry Moors and the
Angelina Jolie like it started kind of
bringing it to the like if you had a
tattoo a cute one it was okay you know
and then the TV shows like blew up and
then everybody has a tattoo now and it's
kind of boring but um but I feel like
ever since I started blacking out my
tattoos I feel like I went back to the
time where people hated tattoos again
cuz people just do not like this they
like they're very confused by why I'm
doing this every time I post progress
shots it's always like why are you doing
this to yourself like this is so ugly
like this is you know I think it looks
for some reason I I didn't know what I
think it looks nice I I did too I like I
like the simping yeah it's almost
fascinating in a strange way like it's
like the inverse of something yeah
exactly you know it's like that car it's
like car I don't know what it is um but
it's yeah it's I'm not not I don't like
pain so I you know I just numb myself up
and you know he sits there and Tattoos
me when you say numb yourself what do
you put on an anales or something you
topal anesthetics like like like a cream
does that work really yeah I mean it
saves me like a good an hour and a half
or something like that yeah no I can't
do pills I can't do anything like yeah
yeah oh yeah yeah I can't do nothing
like that boy nope I don't do no pills
Bubby yeah um and so how much now you're
going to get 80% of your body done no
I'm going to do all of it your whole
body's going to be in a in a uh in dark
ink uhhuh your whole body's going to be
in dark ink yeah and now but but it'll
have like sections that are like you
know like see how there okay so parts
that aren't yeah yeah yeah oh
interesting wow it's almost like
uh it reminds me of like stained glass
or something for some reason um it it'll
look nice like like people people need
to trust the process it'll look good at
the end yeah if anybody has an eye for
something that's unique or trying to do
something new I like that yeah it seem
like you would be at least granted
that ability to experiment yeah oh yeah
here's a video of you right here yeah so
that's like my last session I
did wow I after what is that boy is that
a damn cake cutter that's 40 needles God
damn brother that
thing wow
wow yeah that's cool do you think you'll
go back to tattooing or do you still do
it
um is that a weird question I don't I
don't know a ton about tattooing no no
it's cool um yeah I think I'll I'll
always want to tattoo until my eyesight
goes or something but I don't know if
I'm interested in doing um like I I just
you know I I stopped doing tattoos for
money decades ago it's been like you
know almost like 15 years or something
like I I just tattoo my friends you know
oh yeah yeah because I think uh the
dynamic is can be pretty intense
sometimes if you're tattooing like
people you don't know you know so CU
you're like in a room together
intimately for like you know hours
you're stuck in there sometimes have it
been a nightmare being stuck in a room
with somebody uh I'm never alone but
like usually when I used to tattoo
strangers but uh but now you know
um I just tattoo my friends do people
like say they hire you for like specific
a guest T like is that kind of thing
happen as a tattoo artist like when you
get to have a claim as a tattoo artist
do they say like I want you to come and
do my tattoo like I want to hire you
like oh like how do how do you book an
appointment you mean or or like
specifically like does that happen like
some people might like uh com commiss no
what's it called commission commission
yeah yeah yeah I mean I would always
yeah yeah I mean it kind of works that
way like people when I used to take a
appointments it would be more like
they'd have to show me what they wanted
to get and have like you know a little
bit of the backstory that kind of thing
and then we would have like a booking
process but now do people does it ever
you get a ring from like a prince of
like nodding ham or something and they
want to does that happen to yeah and I
don't like that okay I don't like when
people like like want me to go to them
cuz like first of all it's like you're
creating a sterile environment and so
like I don't want to do that in your
kitchen you know I done that like a few
times for for my friends friends but
like I something about like I don't know
I don't like feeling like a like a
stripper or something oh so the okay
there's something about that then oh
yeah that's interesting yeah oh I would
hate to be a
stripper I would be so bad at
it